class warfare through dance also movie
promises to blend street dancing with
ballet dancing which regardless of what
happens from this point on is a fucking
sin man also didn't Julia Stiles already
do that and save the last dance nope
these are not the protagonists of this
movie but we wanted to get one crane
shot in this thing before the crane
people noticed it was missing
can anyone do a lap does it look like I
need to do a lap guys guys it's the
woman who needs to do the lap dude puts
attention getting LED sign reading
skinny right next to his penis Channing
Tatum is Channing of course the one
white guy who can dance picks the one
girl on the dance floor with a jealous
boyfriend also movie Burroughs the
racism subplot from Save the Last Dance
do you feel like because you're a white
boy you got to overcompensate sometime
that is exactly it actually also yes why
do you think there's a market for a drug
called extends vandalism is hilarious
yeah I can't believe you for teasing no
that was not a fight that was some joing
and one dude pulled a gun so the smart
guys walked away but not a fight Oh
something trash fight awesome dancer
just happens to smash the windows of
dance schools so that he can crime his
way into the dance school plot a new
shot they must is pretty nice though
overly homophobic dance crazy characters
assume this compliment is gay now that
we've destroyed one thing on this stage
and feel bad about it time to destroy
everything on this stage and not feel
bad about it vandalism is hilarious you
know what this high school needs a
couple of undercover cops to stop
rampant crime like this even if this
security guard was sleeping it took him
until the entire stage was trashed to
hear these guys and do something about
it this is just like in war when one
soldier stays behind to buy the others
time to escape only not anything like
that at all well your foster parents
probably dead right considering Tyler's
a real age two hundred hours of
community service to be performed at the
scene of the offence that'll be just
enough time for you to fall in love with
the hot girl who loses her partner for
the big showcase at the end of the movie
movie expects us to believe white people
are capable of being poor there's a
great big world out there and how do I
fit in it cliche samuel l.jackson as
Gandhi with antlers
this hallway is an orgy of evidence that
this is a fine arts high school well I
see being sent to this principal's
office would be no punishment whatsoever
love interest sudden boyfriend is
destined to be an asshole because movie
friends that got off scot-free pull up
exactly as Tyler estate
out the trash and therefore able to
speak with them a moment about leaving
here for you to drive over to almost
there in Baltimore they just mentioned
Omar and there hasn't been one McNulty
sighting it would like the girls on
Mackenzie shot videos they look nothing
like those girls but I guess easy rap
song reference also all hot girls look
alike Tyler mock dances for his friends
so he can be discovered like the Good
Will Hunting of Dancing how long he has
a license six months out of seven if
this girl's 16 then I'm 22 this
motherfucker is still dancing I mean
this guy can't stop and he won't stop
amazing when hot women do this it's sort
of endearing but when I do this at a
high school it's considered creepy
street basketball zine included in this
dance film just in case you were getting
uncomfortable with seeing dudes dance
and enjoying it white men can't jump
really discount Captain Jack Sparrow in
me and her dance partner injured his
foot just after she noticed the uncouth
community-service white boy from the
hood could dance what are the odds
Channing Tatum isn't doing drugs with
Jonah Hill while undercover in this high
school
mopping high school floors during class
breaks that's a paddlin janitors do not
vacuum classrooms during the actual
school day you know all the stuff I've
gone on with the labels and everything
boyfriend suddenly becomes too busy
right after she saw the janitor and his
mad dancing skills yesterday also why
have a dance partner and a boyfriend
when you can just have them both in one
person all I needed so much to rehearse
with just for a couple of weeks T says
now this conversation is happening just
with an ear shot of the white guy with
mad dancing skills this should just call
this movie coincidence up I'm just so
close with my music I got to give it
everything I have right now movie wants
us to hate this guy for wanting to focus
on his art but sympathize with the
girlfriend for wanting to focus on her
art thank you guys so much for coming to
the audition
this chick holds auditions for the role
of her Phil in dance rehearsal partner
and forces them to all audition in front
of one another unacceptable male dancer
montage in full view of the male
protagonists you know you're not gonna
use me to get out of cleaning the
windows that isn't remotely what he
wants to use you for also you were
absolutely busted watching him dance
earlier what is this the female version
of it wasn't me I can't believe there's
no-one else none who have the time
remember her partner's due back by the
time of the showcase so she has to get
permission from the principal on who she
practices with 2:30 tomorrow bring your
tights wait he reports at 2:00 p.m. for
his community service they're not
actually gonna let him substitute dance
practice for community service are they
are they
stepdad as a drunk cliche foster parents
feed foster children Hardy's only
through the
magic of Hollywood could I be made to
feel sorry for the rich girl in her
fancy dinner and jealous of the poor
foster kids and their hearties oh wait
maybe we are about to see the wire it's
taking longer than usual to get to the
meat of this season isn't it kind of a
slow burn but eventually we'll find out
that the Maryland School of Arts is a
breeding ground for drug-dealing piano
maestro's remember our deal Nora if you
don't get a job from the showcase you go
to school in the fall
rich mom sends her amazing dancer
daughter to hipster school for artsy
children all the way through 12th grade
but distrust the arts enough to force
this kind of ultimatum on her boyfriend
no time to help hot girl with dance
rehearsal has time to watch and mocks at
dance rehearsal Tyler's just here until
answers yeah and why is this the first
time I'm hearing about it yeah no
kidding I mean the principal knows her
boyfriend knows they danced out in the
open how does her best friend not know I
can't watch honey you can watch through
the glass okay ha I know there's no way
the community service guy who trashed
this school's auditorium while drunk
would be allowed here alone with a
single other student after hours but
whatever they're starting to fall in
love shadows make a cool romantic shot
he's so rough around the edges that the
prim and proper girl has to patiently
show him the subtle nuances of her
version of the arc I like this movie
better the first time I saw it when it
was called the cutting edge roll credits
damn with rehearsal outfits like this I
definitely should have taken up dancing
in high school at least with girls
dancing this is the exact moment Jenna
Dewan fell in love with Channing Tatum
when it took us until 21 Jump Street
there is no way this team with a third
wheel named skinny is consistently
beating other street basketball teams to
earn money this is the song that keeps
Brett too busy to help his girlfriend so
I brought close studio that must be why
the door is wide open
can't we just rehearse not know there's
other dancers in the studio now because
you can only dance in a studio
apparently where were you oh no did he
quit damn I thought for sure he was the
guy skinny's time to shine quit
everything he thought and you know it
random argument with best friend
contains the very wisdom Tyler needs to
change his mind about dancing with a
rich chick so we gonna go back to doing
this no no I don't trust you girl who
just explained she has nothing if she
doesn't nail the showcase decides that
not trusting her only available
rehearsal partner is a better plan than
taking him back and rehearsing movie
makes a big deal out of Tyler quitting
and then resolves the issue in four
minutes
they hired this girl specifically for a
movie trailer moment didn't they also
this whole scene seems manufactured for
a movie trailer
busiest dancing chick has to teach a
little girl ballet class all of a sudden
since when
guru who doesn't trust her dance partner
reverses that position after one
slapstick comedy routine why are you
yeah I know weird right it didn't come
up until just now so you'd have that
bonding moment some strange where was
dad he died a couple years ago
superheroes always have to have dead
parents cliche oh wait this is basically
her character her hopes and dreams are
tied to noir getting together with Tyler
she's like the audience but with a
player pay actually really good think we
should do it yeah you should totally
change your mind and your routine just
before the big showcase that means
everything see they could have danced
here even anywhere with a flat surface
you know that time Tyler was late the
studio was filled up in the movie wasted
our time what a bunch of bull that was
too bad Nora doesn't know Brett as a
total asshole yet despite all the clues
if she kisses Tyler now she will get
such a slut shaming
hopefully they'll resolve that in five
minutes how do you know they're good
enough or not you know I was good enough
well yeah she did she went through a
bunch of auditions of terrible dancers
and then chose you because she'd seen
you dance
Omaha that's all later all right now
give pissed sohow to timely play street
ball with these guys earlier when he was
doing the community service and the
dancing at the same time this didn't
become an issue until the movie needed
another conflict made you decide to
change her piece
um the script definitely not logic or
common sense dog boyfriend the movie
wants to get rid of to make way for the
Tyler nor a love story conveniently does
something asshole we two pissed Nora off
and trigger a breakup about me or miles
or any that about Tyler isn't it
discount Jonathan Rhys Meyers is right
it is about Tyler mainly because the
plot Camellia pushed him into this
school had Nora's partner sprained an
ankle had Brett on the verge of
recording contract where he sold out his
friend and that happens just after
Thailand Nora had a moment on the
shipping dock
what the fuck calm Emma shut up he's got
a cool to me man
nope he's a singer this movie has
already told me that singers are
assholes we can go ahead and just start
the countdown for miles at his big
chance with Lucy right now I don't know
it's got yourself into character breaks
the fourth wall to speak directly to the
audience they should have called this
movie waste up because it is very
disinterested in showing us actual steps
I just want to take a quick moment to
remind everyone that these are putting
high school students yeah let them go
it's time for the movie to change
perspective out of nowhere after
focusing solely on Norah and Tyler for a
full hour every person this movie needs
us to hate goes from seemingly normal to
asshole boyfriend like the screenplay is
flipping a switch also this has got to
be the stupidest boyfriend in the
history of boyfriends
oh damn I thought we were gonna skip
this part shouldn't they have already
walked to wherever they were gonna walk
and be about to kiss already
I brought your shoes no no little girl
you brought him the most giant orange
juice in the world how did she not fall
over what foster homes are awesome
practicing and falling in love montage
wasn't the big showcase in two weeks
when all this started since that time
Tyler came for practice then quit for
two days came back added new steps and
answers to the peace nor broke up with
her boyfriend they started dating and
now they're practicing again so why did
she need anyone for two weeks if she had
Oh months to prepare for this thing I
just thought she may be smart enough to
know you deserve better by the way guys
this never works but the movie will make
it work also guy wearing this hat
lectures someone else about being smart
he was supposed to meet me at the courts
two hours ago Tyler hasn't been playing
street basketball for weeks since when
does he make promises to play basketball
then he never intends to keep if it was
so important to Mack why hasn't he found
a replacement by now
so you've messed around with our
friendship for girl here comes the big
boy loses girl scene all because his
friend guilt trips him about hanging out
and being derelict in his street
basketball duties it's actually amazing
this didn't come to a head sooner but
it's just about time for Andrew to come
back from his ankle sprain anyway also
man this is just like insane last dance
when the boyfriends hood friends got mad
at him for choosing dance over
participating in a drive-by only you
know basketball instead of killing but
still Andrew comes back from his ankle
sprain while Tyler and Mac argued for
two minutes outside guy who knew all
along he was only a fill-in dancer for
rehearsal gets mad when the guy everyone
knew was coming back for the real
performance actually comes back because
the power of boners is stronger anger
hoodie also everyone who sat in a movie
has to ride the bus depression
headphones you and I both know I can't
pull this routine off
thank God the fill-in dancer came up
with a routine the trained dancer is
incapable performed
that smooth things over perfectly I feel
really bad for him I mean if she doesn't
get to dance for a living she'll have to
go to Cornell a man just like being a
prostitute
madness is perfectly so that the rebound
truce balances towards a magically
appearing Tyler and turned his back on
his boy deserves a second chance
because talking do you know even when
you were a baby you could dance better
than you could walk erin has a sudden
change of heart after the kid stops
pursuing her dream cliche Miles ex
machina skinnies mom knows this kid
doesn't pay attention or follow orders
but somehow expects skinny to stay home
when there's absolutely no punishment
for breaking set orders look like no
Oscar cat to me the hells are not school
cats opposed to the thing yeah you tell
him Heavy D skinny gets kicked out of
the party just in time for a seen this
dance movie badly needed skinny stealing
PJ's Escalade with the pinkies left in
the ignition
DJ can I get over your table real quick
yeah you go because DJ's a popular clubs
are always down for handing over the
deejaying duties to random club goers
there is no way PJ knew the thief would
drive to Omar's party also we interrupt
the state movie with lots of dancing in
it to bring you boys in the hood I guess
I'm supposed to feel bad for this kid oh
well I tried you know what funerals get
me in the mood for a big dancing
showcase finale mother's gone and that's
all me ty I know that nope it's
definitely on skinny you come somewhere
with me I know your brother died and you
hate that I spent all that time at the
MSA but could you drive me to the MSA
he's just gonna show up on the night of
the performance after Nora Shirley had
made plans then changes to her routine
to do solo after days or weeks of not
rehearsing together and of course it'll
be flawless
why can't his return be a few days
earlier still be emotional and then we
just cut to the performance so that I
can actually buy what you're selling
without choking
Tyler this is the second time in this
damn movie you've had her standard round
and then change her mind just as he's
walking away that's laziness
that's copy/paste screenwriting it's
also such a transparent attempt to
manufacture tension whether or not you
realize it and actually creates no
tension whatsoever for the audience why
does this girl's routine have a huge
section in the middle where she's
standing in the back facing the wall and
a bunch of non showcasing dudes get to
jam and everyone got professional dance
contracts significant others and perhaps
most importantly eternal happiness both
the rich kids school hating best friend
and the dance pooh-poohing mom are
completely swayed in their opinions by
the power of dance you've put on me
twice let's make out movie leads YouTube
for some graphics to accompany the end
credits 200 hours of community service
to be performed at the scene of the
offense
ramaa you are not scared of anything I
don't me I'm scared of everything I'm
scared of what I saw I'm scared of what
I did of who I am
Marty that was very interesting music ah
yeah oh I hope you don't mind but George
asked if he could take me home
great good good rain the green juice
science